the super low-slung honda nsx glides
along the road fans have had to wait
more than a decade for the new addition
of this super sports car now it's
finally out and packed with hybrid
technology
mata says automakers normally use ibrid
technology to save fuel the whole
driving experience can sometimes suffer
in the process but the Honda NSX is
different here hybrid technology has not
been used to save fuel primarily but to
increase the fun factor that's his kind
of hybrid my name is Luca the
combination of a v6 twin-turbo
mid-engine and three electric motors
delivers a stonking 429 kilowatts of
power
montes finds most super sports cars tend
to be a little too responsive on the gas
pedal you touch it even just slightly in
the car starts to buck like a wild bull
but the Honda NSX is not only a lot more
smooth that also offers varying drive
modes so you can switch to the quiet
mode if you want a more relaxed Drive
and thanks to the hybrid technology you
can glide in or out of your driveway
without a sound if it's early in the
morning or late at night and you don't
want to disturb the neighbors in diamond
and dance Cavazos survive speed Morgans
flu or - red arms hours or the Indian
fad for an owner done wound on get him
off to find another shaft with a height
of just over one meter 20 the NSX is one
of the lowest and most streamlined
sports cars out there the cockpit is
well to the front the body contours are
as sharp as a blade keeping side vents
helped to underline the sporty
aggressive look
19-inch wheels and a huge braking system
served to bring the whole thing to a
speedy halt if necessary all in all it's
a car that will definitely turn heads
the interior is very much tailored to
the needs of the driver and there aren't
many control buttons to worry about
while driving the NSX is only available
with a nine speed double clutch
transmission and don't even bother
looking for a gear stick Matis has to
admit he's pretty fussy about the
interior of his cars he wants everything
to not just look good but feel good too
unfortunately he finds that Japanese
cars often look fine but when you run
your hands over the inside it feels
cheap but the Honda NSX not only looks
stunningly beautiful it also feels great
too the materials are really
high-quality and the layout is very
attractive with the different materials
that have been used it's top-notch the
price tag is also top-notch
the NSX will set you back one hundred
eighty thousand euros in Germany but it
has a top speed to match blasting to 308
kilometers per hour
montes says it feels like the car is
gliding on Rails the two electric motors
of the front pull the car in exactly the
direction you want it's really not bad
at all there's no hint of over or under
steering and the way the car takes bends
is great he's driven a lot of cars and a
lot of fast cars too but this takes
things to a new level
but then the NSX isn't just a sports car
for the road of course it's also been
built for the racetrack pretty large
transit abouts on an owl through the
avenge taker so Matas goes to the
Estoril circuit and portugal where a
right-hand drive NSX with racing tires
awaits Minka mantas has his left foot on
the brake right foot on the gas he has
launch mode ready and all he needs to do
is release the brake
you can watch the smile on the drivers
face grow as the car Sprint's to 100
km/h in just three seconds Monta says
when you're on the racetrack you have to
switch driving modes the standard one is
sport you need to select either Sport
Plus for a bit more fun or track for a
lot more fun the ESP is reduced by half
so it kicks in a lot later the engine
goes from a / to a roar and you can
really let rip reducing the ESP makes it
possible for the driver to use drift a
key racing technique and thanks to
assistance from the electric motors
drifting is made a lot easier for
someone who's not used to doing it every
day
the challenge with drifting is that you
risk losing control of the car but the
front axles to electric motors pull the
car exactly in the direction you're
steering and that makes drifting a lot
easier with the NSX making it keeps more
fun and of course safer to boot the NSX
is almost flat to the ground but the
driver still doesn't feel every bump in
the road the performance is breathtaking
as of today Montes has changed his mind
Honda can't just make small safe
economical cars it can also produce a
super sports car it's really good kind
of tough thankfully Oh super sports body
but only a select group of customers is
likely to ever enjoy the NSX apart from
the price tag the cars are built by hand
and the plan is to produce only a
limited number each year
if you were thinking of buying a station
wagon the Citroen c5 t'rar is probably
not the first thing that would spring to
mind but could it be a genuine
alternative to the leading cars in the
segment a Manuel Schaefer is keen to
find out
he says the car he's testing uses a 2
liter diesel engine with 133 kilowatts
and 180 horsepower and he can certainly
feel that it really moves the version
he's testing is an automatic with six
gears allowing you to just glide along
with the traffic without having to keep
changing gears so it's ideal for those
who do lots of driving the c5 can move
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in 9.7
seconds and has a top speed of 219
the c5 is equipped with soot twins
haider active 3 plus suspension which
automatically adjusts the right height
to suit the road surface but adjustments
can also be made by pressing this button
so emmanuelle can set it high or very
low or anywhere in between
the c5 also is a sports setting which
gives you a more dynamic suspension when
sport mode is activated the c5 has a lot
more grip on corners and the driving
experience is definitely more fun the
exterior has sleek lines which give it
an elegant look made a little more
dynamic by the headlights but in profile
it still kept the typical station wagon
shape as helped me hit the minor wall
has decided to try out the backseat and
as he expected there's plenty of legroom
there's a hand width of space still left
and the front seat is slanted in here so
there's a comfortable amount of room for
your knees in comte past
the trunk offers nearly five hundred
thirty three litres of space up to the
ledge here where you can pull out the
cover but what emanuelle finds really
interesting is the hide rack of three
plus suspension which allows you to move
the rear axle up and down to make it
easier for loading and unloading cargo
I'm glad ability or w- had poor Tom's
AHA I know dollars two Laden this only
works when the car is at a standstill of
course as soon as you start the engine
the height is automatically adjusted to
match the front axle
oh and all your mana well thinks the c5
is definitely a success the only thing
that disturbs him slightly is the
controls in the middle the steering
wheel turns but they all stay in the
same place which takes some getting used
to one time in mind while nearly trapped
his finger while turning the steering
wheel but otherwise he finds it an
extremely comfortable car to drive the
suspension irons away all the bumps in
the road and the seats are also really
comfortable in fact it's so comfortable
he says you might not want to drive it
if you were very tired as you could be
asleep in no time prices for the c5
Taurus start at just over 33,000 euros
our test car which came with the
exclusive trim level and a 133 kilowatt
diesel engine will cost you at least 42
thousand euros
Daimler has unveiled a futuristic
concept car the vision mercedes maybach
six mercedes says the two plus
two-seater pays homage to the glory days
of the Aero coupe A's and consciously
carries that tradition forward the
electric vehicle is almost 6 meters long
and has an output of 550 kilowatts three
years after launching the three GT BMW
is giving the model a facelift the new
three GT looks much sporty-er there is a
choice of three gasoline and five diesel
engines they're turbocharged and more
powerful than their predecessors and BMW
claims they're up to 14% more efficient
than previous models
small formula racing cars and cheering
students come together at the Formula
Student in Germany
111 teams from universities all over the
world met at Hockenheim this year but
winning isn't everything here one
student says being successful at the end
of the season is obviously a worthwhile
goal and that's also important for
motivating the team and helping you to
feel enthusiastic about the next season
but what he likes is the whole
atmosphere of the Formula Student events
you get to talk with the other teams and
discuss various technical issues if he
has a problem he loves to go to all the
other teams we always find someone who
can help the events are not primarily
about racing the cars have all been
built by the students a huge jury made
up of representatives from the
automotive industry judges the results
looking at technical application
functionality and practicality you
remember Stefan D says there are top
teams here who work very professionally
some of the technology is high-end where
you ask yourself how they managed it but
there are also teams with very basic
designs and they still get their car
running there too it's fascinating to
see how they know all the ins and outs
of their car the vehicles are really put
through their paces one of the trials
involves an acceleration test
car handling exercises on a wet circuit
also show how good the designs are in
practice the Formula Student is very
much about teamwork one student says the
team doesn't just build a car it's more
like setting up a mini business every
year his team is composed of around 60
people they also have to take care of
marketing and organizational matters
then there's project management as a
complex project that they have here
especially with the marketing and
liaison with sponsors between tents the
students keep working on the cars
there's always room for improvement
Phillip Gottlieb says the students are
working on technology of the future that
could later be sold his team has built
an electric racing car
he believes they'll play an important
role in a mobility because they're
helping to get young engineers familiar
with the technology and he and his team
members will probably be the engineers
who will later build these cars leading
lights in the automotive industry take a
similar view and have come here to look
for potential employees
both wagons Montana low success
there are engine specialists here
mechanical engineers all the IT jobs are
represented business and economics all
the kinds of people that Volkswagen
needs VW also sponsored several teams
sponsoring here involves more than just
financial help it's about sharing
expertise kay'est Easler says the
sponsors work closely with the team at
the start of the season during the
design phase they try to get together
with their sponsors the sponsors also
offer a lot of support during the
production phase making sure the parts
the students design can be produced and
that the ideas from the sponsor are
incorporated early on in the process I'm
at I'm blinkin the automotive industry
also puts up a number of prizes Mercedes
awarded a prize for the best electric
car singling out the engineers who could
well be the ones to build the
emissions-free car of the future
anyone who's ever used a Mercedes
Sprinter for a move knows just how much
furniture can fit inside but this heimer
car isn't your standard multipurpose
Sprinter it's a fully equipped camper
van that was developed by heimer and
Mercedes designed to meet your every
need while on holiday our car tester
Michelle Assenmacher is throwing out the
Grand Canyon s it's based on the
Mercedes Sprinter and has tailor-made
furniture from heimer the vehicle is
five point nine three meters long and
seats four people the seats can be
arranged around a table
there's plenty of storage space thanks
to the many cupboards but the vehicle
never seems cramped due to a
well-designed interior we all tend to
take lots of stuff on holiday but there
are enough drawers for storing
everything but to ensure nothing goes
flying around the van while driving the
drawers come with special catches to
lock them all you need to do is push the
buttons the Grand Canyon s is also
fitted with a small kitchen so no one
needs to go hungry there's a hob with
two rings under this cover and a small
sink
and there's a tall fridge besides the
kitchen unit offering plenty of space
and of course no campervan is complete
without a toilet and a shower they're
located here the basin is fitted onto
the side wall and can be folded away to
save space it comes with a pull-out
water tap that can also be used for
showering the show points out there's a
shower curtain to prevent everything
from getting wet what more could you ask
for the Grand Canyon s also comes with
comfy mattresses unlike many other
camper vans where seating areas double
up as beds dare Grand Canyon the Grand
Canyon is is cleverly laid out Michele
demonstrates another space-saving
feature
the Vans rear can be quickly transformed
into a cozy bed for two and in
summertime you can look through the rear
doors onto the sea while you're nodding
off Conestoga auf das meer blinking on
table and laughing
Michelle likes the Grand Canyon has a
lot she finds regular campervans just
too big for people our age but this
smaller van is really to her liking
tough canal - mark
and so there's a campervan for every
taste smaller and more agile vans like
this one are beginning to match up to
the bigger ones in terms of features and
they weigh less so in many countries no
special driver's license is necessary
only 178 of these vintage models were
ever built an auto enthusiast and Elias
Moser is lucky enough to own one this
BMW 319 one dates from 1936 he says it's
important to keep both hands on the
wheel if only because the vehicle is
pretty sensitive when it comes to over
or under steering
the BMW 319 debuted in 1934 with a then
new 1.9 liter 6-cylinder engine it
looked identical to its predecessor the
315 one sport but boasted an additional
15 horsepower the 319 cost a cool six
thousand Weiss marks a princely sum back
then nearly four times what an average
worker earned in a year
Andrea says the way the BMW logo is
connected to the two grills is typical
of BMW everything on this car is
absolutely original here are the lights
which all date to the pre-war period
that's why it's missing a certification
seal andreas really likes the cars
almost open style and what's called
ancient style shifter ystos his tools
here the kit consists largely of
original items he likes the cars
contours in particular especially the
way they look when studied from the side
the wheel housings are also covered they
lend an aerodynamic touch that prevents
the tires from vibrating iDEN this BMW
didn't always glisten the way it does
today
andreas restored it himself and knows
every screw and knob apparently the
vehicle was ripe for restoration because
it had been involved in a car accident
as such many parts were broken the car
had to be completely rebuilt tie-in
kaput so does this outer edge completely
off keep out red Mazda the frame was set
on wooden dollies he had to bring in an
expert to refashion the wood but that
wasn't the hardest part of the
restoration the most demanding port for
andreas was actually examining the
engine one major issue was that back
when the car was built different bearing
shells were used in the crankshaft he
didn't want to install any previously
used pieces he wanted instead to use
something made of modern materials the
significant restoration work on the
engine and the body was worth it after a
total of 14 years working on the BMW the
319 won today almost looks like a brand
new car yet it doesn't seem over
restored prices for a model in such good
condition as this one will set you back
around a
a million euros on the weekend andreas
takes part in vintage car events and the
vehicle isn't spared the wear and tear
of such trips andreas drives it to such
events rather than getting it
transported he wants to enjoy every
moment he can at the wheel
Deadites he loves the sound of the
engine and the views of his surroundings
because it's a convertible or a roadster
you can appreciate nature and speed more
in a car like this than you would in one
of today's modern cars he took the car
to a BMW veteran club event in the
Austrian Alps the cars embark on a 300
kilometer journey any BMW older than
1981 is eligible to take part in the
drive
Stars big and small from BMW editions of
the past took part including the
legendary BMW Isetta the 319 one runs
with the best of BMWs many vintage
models the car delivers 55 horsepower
through its straight six-cylinder engine
and it weighs a mere 700 80 kilograms
top speed is 135 km/h the 319 is
considered the first sports car for the
road that was also used on the racetrack
but the car is not perfect and there are
some detailing issues that andreas Moser
has noticed in his work on the car for
example a problem with the gas tank
makes driving uphills problematic
andreas explains how the production
mistake is visible the tank is trapezoid
shaped this is the line connecting the
oil filter and then this connects to the
pump when he drives up a hill the tank
rotates and as a result the gas pools at
the rear of the tank and doesn't flow
the way it should if you're unlucky he
adds a steep incline can cause the gas
flow to cease and the engine to turn off
Andreas knows every wrinkle of his BMW
his tour and the drive back home went
off without a hitch
he tries to clock up at least 8,000
kilometers every year with his 319 won
because like many of his fellow vintage
car buffs he feels these cars should see
the open road as often as possible